dans la terreur de footballeur c'est mes
plus belles années je les ai passées
reste monaco centre de formation il y en
a beaucoup qui le disons mais même moi
qui vit des choses exceptionnelles
je pense que je retrouverai jamais ce
que j'ai vécu à l'as monaco et vous
impossible alors vous avez vu quoi c'est
un quotidien en fait c'est que à partir
du moment où tu te réveilles tu es avec
tes potes tu es en confiance mais à
3000% pas de filtre pas de pression tu
te soucie pas du lendemain thello j'ai
été nourri et tout ce que tu vis et un
qui fait tilt kif à 200% et le piège
c'est que ça peut pour nous ça devenait
quelque chose de normal alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas du tout normales
même si elle réussit tu peux t'on m
c'est un truc parce qu'à la fin à la fin
de ta journée tu es un homme comme tout
le monde que tu peux devant les gens
faire croire que la fin quand tu te
regarde dans le miroir c'est ta tronche
quoi donc
c'est ni l'argent ni la notoriété ni
macha qui va te rendre heureux ils se
connaissent depuis qu'ils sont à dos ils
ont partagé plusieurs années ensemble au
centre de formation de l'as monaco avec
un verre en commun
devenir joueur professionnel de football
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui abdou et défenseur au paris
saint germain et international
sénégalais anthony joue en deuxième
division en suisse lounis a arrêté le
foot pour devenir agent de joueurs et
dylan
absent lors de l'entretien tout en 4e
division en angleterre cette adolescence
pas comme les autres ils ont décidé de
la raconter dans un livre qu'ils ont
écrit ensemble pendant le premier
confinement loin des terrains de
football
la voix de m c'est pourquoi j'ai obligé
pour brut
ils reviennent sur ces années là était
vraiment on était tout le temps ensemble
et mêmes notre force et accusent sur le
terrain et même en dehors extra football
on faisait les activités ensemble
c'était et puis après je sais pas pour
vous mais moi à titre personnel cette
bienveillance la gelée pas retrouvé dans
le football après mois on faisait des
soirées ligue des champions à 15 dans un
appart way est pas prêt personnes
voulaient voir les pizzas près de
personnes voulaient me ramener parce que
moi j'étais le plus jeune donc moi
j'avais pas le permis les mecs qui
avaient permis ou voulais pas me ramener
rester une petite mission est
aujourd'hui j'imagine que vous faites de
soirée des champions au nord du sahara
exactement et c'est là c'est la fierté
franchement ça fait plaisir et par
exemple comme l'a dit mais moi par
exemple maintenant exacte et le ballon
je vis je vis à travers lui quand ils
jouent tous en fait ça fait ça fait
super plaisir
non c'est une fierté ont bel et bien
réussi et ça c'est ce qui fait que on a
duré tout son sens que si elle commence
à faire la star au poids je pense que le
réparer mais non tu me cinéma / s'est
formé ensemble mais c'est aussi faire
ses études ensemble
bah oui bien sûr mais encore une fois ce
n'est pas un étudiant lambda tas
d'autres idées en tête à d'autres
créatif dans les horaires aménagés en
fait tu adaptes pas scolarité à ton
sport donc forcément que dans ta tête tu
décroches et mais tout tourne autour du
football était calibré pour toi tu veux
pas être tu veux pas être médecin c'est
ça être bruyant professionnels donc tu
suis les études parce que voilà on te
dit il le faut et il faut un certain
bagage
c'est ce qui est normal mais pendant ta
tête tu es formaté tu veux finir
footballeur professionnel c'est super
dangereux il y en a qui prenait les
études à ça à la légère
on a qu'à 90 points qu'ils essaient de
mettre un suivi etc
mais même plus rares même si tu as le
diplôme moi j'ai eu le bac pagne mais
personnellement je ne faisais rien sur
les cours on n'a pas la même jeunesse
que les autres si tu veux réaliser ton
rêve tu peux pas avoir la même jeunesse
et au final on avait même du mal un peu
à se faire des amis en dehors du foot
en fait tu es tellement fou de foot foot
foot que ton esprit il ya un petit peu
fermé tu vois de temps en temps il y en
a qui aujourd'hui même à notre âge
n'auront pas ce recul là et il ne pense
qu'au foot mais on est formaté
clairement on s'en rend compte trop
toujours trop tard toujours quand tu
rentres chez tes parents dans ton
quartier avec tes potes d'avant pour ta
réussite et la star donc déjà d'office
c'est dur d'avoir du recul et de garder
les pieds sur terre mais moi je sais que
barry c'était notre entraîneur donc on
me disait vous le répétez souvent on
avait des joueurs très talentueux
10 aces à certains niveaux le talent ça
suffit plus quoi est il disait fallait
vraiment travailler et nous disait que
vous verrez que tout en vous retrouverez
pas forcément c'est auquel vous pensez
plus jeune et ça s'est avéré on parle de
vous deux resté accroché à son rêve mais
parce qu'il ya un moment on se dit voilà
débutants me le dise niveau moi
personnellement j'avais vécu de joie je
l'avais que j'adhère à un stade où voilà
ça fait que je n'avais plus l'envié tu
vois [ __ ] il passé c'était plus tout
jeune donc je me suis posée j'ai
réfléchi et je me suis dit essayer
d'utiliser ce que j'ai appris au centre
pour essayer de tirer un maximum de
choix mais mais ouais c'est vrai que
c'est dur at il avoué en fait tu vois
les musulmans à toi même et said et
essaie de gagner du temps après au bout
d'un moment tu te suis trop souvent
l'accès à la casse du coup de fusil par
écoute je veux toujours devenir
quelqu'un tu vois j'ai cette envie cette
mentalité de gagnant on va voir la place
entre autres dans un autre monde je vois
ton pote qui s'apprête à jouer une
finale des champions tu te dis quoi
pas moi je comprends pas ce que je suis
en contact avec eux je suis ces îles
sont ils sont comme moi quoi j'ai grandi
avec eux donc je comprends et je
comprends encore plus la chance que j'ai
parce que c'est retire du travail certes
ge devrait pour avoir ça mais on
maîtrise pas tout c'est personnellement
je crois en la destinée c'était ma
destinée je pense et j'ai pu j'ai pas le
contrôle sur tout donc j'ai de la
réussite aussi
j'ai rencontré les bonnes personnes j'ai
été au bon endroit au bon moment et je
sais que c'est une chance maintenant
je pense que comme comme étudiant en ce
moment à nous mêmes parce qu'on nous a
toujours dit que ce qui est bien c'est
sans douleur que ce qui vaut quelque
chose c'est le foot
et donc si on veut pas de foot dans vos
quoi c'est ça en fait tout ça c'est ça
la vraie question qui je pense se pose
et en faisant d'autres projets en
s'intéressant à d'autres choses
en s'ouvrant et en ce vraiment ce
concentrant fortement sur d'autres
choses comme on a pu faire avec le livre
en fait tu te rends compte que non y a
plein de choses à faire de foot ccc
miettes par rapport à tout ce qu'il ya
comme opportunité et surtout qu'on est
capable de faire n'importe qui et la
famille ou si ça joue beaucoup
on a une certaine pression de la famille
leur environnement il faut absolument
que tu réussisses que tu deviens de
footballeur professionnel
mais ça aussi quand tu es jeune quand tu
as entre 14 et 17 18 ans et ça peut pas
être facile à gérer pour tout le monde
toi tu ressentais de la prison moi
personnellement non c'est non mais je
sais qu autour de moi j'ai envoyé qui
revenons à les géants et non mérité
l'argent moi j'en avais de leur science
il y avait l'argent et puis avait aussi
attaqué après c'est la notoriété aussi
c'est une fierté c'est une certaine
c'est une question mais ils sont fiers
de toi aussi
c
et si ça passe pas et le retour à la vie
normale peut être vraiment aussi brutale
même dans son propre environnement
pression dans un sens ou moi
personnellement je me la mets tu es tout
seul dans sa famille on sait tous on est
jeune on pompe l'on peut tous les sortir
de choix leur quotidien et
financièrement leur faire un bien fou
inconscient mettant 206 été la même si
c'est en gros on s'appelait il me dit en
gros se passe bien est ce que tu as fait
tu vois c'était pas la mesure où il
facture est absolument faux mais le fait
est que je sais d'où tu viens
je sais c'est qu'ils ont du jus ganja
toutes les galères qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
surmontés fatigués obligé d'associer
vois ce que je veux dire donc en soi
ouais tu sais quelque chose de grand en
entamant et what's up talent espoirs de
toute une famille tu vois tout une femme
soit comme si tu peux changer leur vie
et est ce que le fait d'un moment pas
réussir sata soulagé de cette pression
ou de ce bois non au contraire
jusqu'à l'heure actuelle pour moi j'ai
une dette envers eux c'est fou mais tant
que voudrait pas atteint mes objectifs
professionnels
si et voilà d'atteindre les soumettant à
ce que je vais faire maintenant en gmt
vous propose avec cette question parce
que ce qui est fou c'est que quand moi
j'ai signé pro et j'ai eu des soucis que
ça a été très dur je me suis déjà posé
la question si j'avais pas réussi est-ce
que ça n'aurait pas été plus simple ça
dépend alors après rapidement tu
relativises tu dois par contre comme toi
t'as une chance de malades d'être là
mais cette question et bien tu te la
pose d'ailleurs lâché avec des
footballeurs ou des écrivains de se la
raconter un peu
des philanthropes des des potes des
potes on est en famille qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'on kiffe
ça nous et qui fait de faire un livre on
l'a fait on espère que safran qui fait
beaucoup de gens mais des potes sans
aucune prétention